I'm Mike and I think ghosts are [ __ ]
what would gold look like I saw those
busses like Slimer sometimes people lose
loved ones they're attached to the idea
that they could find their loved ones in
a paranormal form in the entire course
of people owning cameras we don't have
one piece of evidence that ghosts exist
if I'm scared it's because I'm in the
dark in the middle of nowhere the only
thing I'm afraid of at night is a
criminal coming up to me and stabbing me
in the throat I'm nervous my heart is
palpitating a little bit I heard that
ghosts get angry when they see red so
I'm human bait
come at me ghost it's gonna be fun I
have a Ghostbusters bill okay's at home
that I believe is real but go sir
we're here at the supposed abandoned
Asylum I'm about to go inside my name is
Chad co-founder of a Medela paranormal
I'm Josh I'm the founder this is an
asylum my head found before it's been
kind of locally known there's no actual
address to this place no real roads here
literally in the middle of nowhere
there's no actual evidence of this being
an asylum it's all folklore like feeling
Jason I'm feeling great I'm actually
more interested in the graffiti we're
gonna be going in through here everybody
be careful a couple things that we've
gotten here we've got a lot of voices me
and Daniel actually hurt a little boy
laughing we've got an EMF hits here
confirming that there is some spirit
that either believes their nurse or was
once a nurse probably fine that you want
to stay closer to the walls those people
feel better in the dark when they have
something behind them keep in mind open
keep your ears open sometimes you'll
feel like a slight touch of breath or I
mean it's it is real subtle you know
just me to just everyone not feel like
they're feeling breaths and touches so I
thought on that okay
someone's trying to whistle or
definitely heard that
what was it so that's what's on there oh
that's what's on there and you heard it
though siren oh yeah for sure
Oh what I got okay a cellphone or
something huh I don't know that's what's
on there okay
so we know the nurse is here to get
lonely here by yourself or are you by
yourself what was that
the moan or what yeah it's something it
was just like a big right here right
yeah brought a lot of people that are
very anxious to meet you
we're here to make them believers are
you gonna help us with that can you
finish this for me what if you use this
spirit box
oh we got now I think I hear some cooler
can you say hello
are you hiding in this one thing and
we're not getting anything right now
you'll see this being fun hang out at
during the day alright everybody's
getting a circle why you can use our
energy can you come over here grab one
of us you know what do you feel anything
yet my wrist got a chi oh my goodness
are you can you make it colder in the
circle seventy three point eight okay no
it's 73 even seventy two point three
keep going keep on so that's a four
degree difference yeah seventy one point
six seventy point 969 it drops seven
degrees yeah in the middle of a circle
of people it should never be colder so
former can we do ninety five degrees
please
I didn't personally see anything or
experienced anything it was just like a
teen hangout spot I wouldn't have been
surprised if we walked in on two
teenagers making out and when you look
up you see the stars and the stars are
actually pretty beautiful this is really
awesome I should go camping here I was
creeped out by imagining the past of the
place as creeped out by imagining what
might have gone on there paranormal or
not there's just something off putting
about that I dug there enthusiast into
this being alone in a mysterious creepy
place that would make me more afraid
it's all about the power of the mind if
you're afraid of something you're
probably going to force that to exist
somehow in your mind you can believe
whatever you want I'm not going to be
the one to be like you're fake you're
bull whatever there's a world of things
humans can't perceive you could go see
err ethically be one of those things
sure but that's just as likely as like
cat monsters that eat squids it's just
so sad what's happening over there oh
yeah you don't know the half